[Music]
all right let's go to charles in
bakersfield california hey charles how
are you
i'm doing great dave and christy how are
you how are you doing
great how can we help well i'm calling
just a little backstory this is
concerning my mother-in-law
she is 76 a widow and
a while back she took out these two home
equity lines of credits
one totaling about twenty six thousand
eight hundred dollars with a five and a
half percent interest rate
i think originally this was around
thirty seven thousand when she started
plus there was a second one that uh she
has never
used and that one i believe has a three
point three percent interest rate
her credit union wants to charge her
130 dollars to remove this second home
equity line of credit
i'm just trying to figure out you know
she is uh
retired and getting roughly 1500
a month in social security uh what are
her options as far as getting out of
this mess
and so there's an open line of credit
that has a zero balance and they just
want to charge her 100 bucks to take it
off the books
yeah i would do that in a heartbeat okay
yeah because that basically that takes
the gun away from the child
okay you know
and uh because i mean if you don't have
the thing you can't use it
right and so it's worth 130 to get it
out of her life because she might
make a bad decision you know yeah and
run that thing up and you don't want
that to happen for sure
okay yeah so she got a budget where she
can live on the 1500
um pretty much i mean she lives with her
oldest
daughter in their home it's it's a
fairly large home
but uh unfortunately her oldest daughter
does not work she was laid off because
of covet 19
and she was a food demonstrator at one
of these uh big membership stores but
they pretty much laid off the whole
staff because
okay so what was the line of credit for
the other one that is open with the 26
000 or whatever you said uh
that i believe was just pretty much for
medical bills she did not have a
a long-term care insurance policy her
husband
became ill he had a parkinson's like
illness plus he had lung cancer
and he had to go through several
treatment facilities just for
getting him back in physically good
health and
but you know he's not around anymore
unfortunately so okay
yeah well let's just get her set up
where she can you know not have the
temptation to use that or
someone else that's unemployed like her
daughter doesn't have the temptation to
talk her into using it because the last
thing this lady needs is debt with this
low in income
and so yeah i would take that i'd pay
130 bucks and get rid of that a
heartbeat
and i'd try to talk him out of charging
me to do it by the way
just for 100 worth of discussion but
it's worth it to get rid of it i i would
get rid of it and then
uh you know obviously she's on a tight
budget and we're going to watch
help her watch her money and uh look
over her shoulder and
you know give her give her some uh
cheerleading advice
um not corrective advice but just
cheerleading and just
you know let her know that you know
you'll help her with the
uh with the numbers if you can help with
uh putting the budget together and
running it sometimes people just need a
little bit of emotional support
let me ask you something on that dave
because it's interesting with the in-law
relationship like
for example how would he encourage her
or help her or even have that
conversation with someone that is his
in-law versus
his own mom like would you advise
differently because i feel like there's
a different
there's a different relationship there
it's probably easier
than with his own mom because it's more
like a friend okay and it's just i'm
just trying to help you yeah you know
it's like if sharon's dad
ask me your question you know i can
certainly tell him you know what i
think and i don't have a lot of
emotional i don't have as much emotional
as if it was my mom
interesting that kind of thing or my dad
you know that kind of thing so
uh it's just i can sit down and say well
this is what i do yeah
you know and then if he doesn't do it
it's up to him right you know
uh but i can coach them and and surely
them along i think it's probably
a little easier there's no conflict
involved here it's just instruction now
where there's conflict you're gonna
bring in the reality yeah